So let's look at another example.
Maybe you say, well, the one I
just gave is not that realistic.
What if everybody takes
the exam at the same time?
Well, that particular attack
will not succeed in that case.
So we're going to craft
a different kind of an attack,
using the same authorized query which
returns the average score on an exam.
So let's say in this case,
we have only one student with
a standing that is junior.
Because the course, let's say,
is a senior course.
And one smart junior student
chose to take it or enroll in it.
So it's a senior class and we only
have one student who is a junior.
It's useful information that we know
where there's groups of students.
Okay, you may ask for the average
scorer, male students, female students,
students who are juniors, students who
are seniors, and things like that.
Because in general, if there are a lot
of junior students, maybe you want to
know how did you perform relative
to your peers who are also juniors.
So let's take the query that says,
which also specifies
the standing of a student, but
it's still asking for average score.
Let's say that's allowed.
So here we get average score of
students when the standing was junior.
So that's where our query says,
where standing equals junior.
In that case, we're still
running the average score query,
so it will take the tuples where
the standing is junior, and
then compute the average on those and
return that value.
Well, that's a problem
if it does do that.
Because in this case, the query's
actually going to disclose the average.
If you're doing average for
one value, then you are actually,
this average discloses the value itself.
So this query, if there's only one
student, of course the result it's
going to return is going to be the score
of the student who had junior standing.
So this is another example
where I think the reason
this happens is that we're computing
the average which is an aggregate,
which is authorized as we said before,
over a small set of tuples for
the exam score values in
tuples that are selected.
In extreme case,
there's only one of these tuples.
And in that case, it's the exact score.
So this query again allows someone to
make an inference, saying the student
who's standing a junior, this, the
average that we get is his or her score.